and welcome to punch-drunk sports here
we are again back in saddle with a bunch
of old friends here showing up latest
[ __ ] who's on time again
damn Triple E always on time every week
every episode I hope you raise your kid
better than you raised this podcast I
was texting on the way I left earlier
than I've ever left so happy it was like
I'm gonna blow everyone's mind and then
ways told me to take the 5 and the 5
clearly is like signs ok it's true
listen let's say construction 5 is
closed it's like how did ways not get
that memo is that a ghost talking cuz we
told you you were dead you've been dead
for a month so here are you alive well
my theory Waze is working with big oil
to get people to drive around spend more
gas you want my Imperial some ways rapes
children gonna be oh we don't do my
dates first yeah
let's then let's go to the joke dates
first I will be at queef Latifah is
comedy Castle in Des Moines Iowa the
29th to the 35th I'm at flat earth cafe
telling lies to Goble idiots tomorrow
tomorrow to yesterday that doesn't make
sense but it doesn't matter to people
that stupid I'm at the big lesbian
festival [ __ ] [ __ ] goose those [ __ ]
ain't playing Louie CK is headlining it
so bring tomatoes and your Twitter and
I'm also at the Comedy Store this week
and uh that's it element of a friend
Dave's house to good old day that's a
great gig this weekend I am at the
Minnesota I'm at the house of comedy in
Minneapolis at the mall yep nice nice
I'm there this weekend the following
weekend I am at the Edmonton comic strip
and then what else we have I have all
next Tuesday is comedy chaos Joe Rogan
Gerry Dee and a couple other people are
in the show so lineups will be out today
we'll see how it goes it is getting
crazy in that main room
everybody's doing way too many shells
everyone's doing double shows yep hello
it what are we hearing - Sam's I can
hear myself why is it playing in real
time - it's amazing it's not playing in
real time it's a delay yeah a delayed
real time we are in real time we are or
are we well clearly we are skewed they
have the hi guys welcome back we had the
whole first time he's been covered in
scratches is that true yeah I scratched
myself hard pretty no [ __ ] I mean that
looks like you could get sepsis I have a
cutter dude I cut myself
no I new thing I mean your attire yeah I
cut myself you shake it's all [ __ ]
good let's go on next thing so what do
you guys think about the [ __ ]
football game which one it's run yeah -
what the ones this weekend he's a thief
of d4 book yeah well I mean obviously
I'm talking Rams versus Saints
everybody's talking about it
was it a wedge dude there were just as
many bad calls in the Chiefs game just
as many I don't know if there was as bad
a call as the bad call and what about
that hands to the face yeah that was not
even close and in speaking the Chiefs
that was third would have been 39 but
instead 15 yards and then he scored the
game-winning touchdown on that same
drive that was his as much as a
game-changing call as the no call was on
pass interference that Pat that non pass
interference call was worse than the
Tuck roll call they've been calling that
[ __ ] all year though the kind of you
brush the guy's helmet and you get hands
to the face
well I still doesn't see where he even
brushed his helmet yeah I mean I think
on the return he just grazed it just a
little bit but I think they shouldn't
call it no he didn't ball no he did it
maybe I think elbow might have hit the
side of his face mask maybe I can't
believe we're talking like this did he
patty-cakes him because they've been
calling patty-cakes
all year in the NFL that well that's
that's why I think that call is not as
bad as the call in the Rams game I mean
because if they've been calling it all
year they gotta call it when the guy
takes a guy's [ __ ] head off you know
it
most important yes and I do a conspiracy
sports podcast so you guys will get this
but aside from the Clintons being
involved let's be honest there's two
things the NFL does two things the NFL
wants yes you're literally looking at
your phone might say sound what you're
saying you're not you're literally not
you're I think you're making a flier for
your nine on their podcast yeah
but there's a pube on the surface why's
it gotta be a pube dude why can't just
be I'm doing a podcast I'm rocking right
now Jeff says the same thing because
he's hairy too and I agree it's not
pubes yeah mermen we're her furry we
must hunt in the forest Ryan oh it's the
same thing he's like I hate going to
your house there's pubes well this is
before he lived with me and I'm like
crazy but he's like it's not pubes dudes
like I just I'm hairy yeah I like is
like some hairs right there and some
ears right there there they're treated -
it's like field slave house slave it's
makes no sense go on you have you a
slave no I'm just saying the NFL there's
two things the NFL there's one thing
they wanted and there's one thing they
didn't want and both happen they don't
want the Saints playing in Atlanta their
biggest enemy in a city with a lot of
violence how much crime would there have
been had the Saints got to play
essentially a home game in their rivals
Stadium that's like Oakland that's like
the Superbowl bein let's say ten years
ago when Oakland had a city and so did
the Chargers yeah and let's say the
Super Bowl is in San Diego it was you
think they want Oakland but they did go
but do you think they wanted that oh it
was either
I mean crime like my pond is this the
Saints know that locker room the Saints
have an obvious advantage they go oh
yeah give us a visit locker room we play
there every year we know we all have our
favorite [ __ ] hangars they have an
obvious advantage the Saints playing in
Atlanta I and the crime would been
through the roof I disagree with that
and the flipside of that what if I said
this Hillary Clinton is
fan now what's up now what's up bro it
makes more now that I think I think
here's the thing you think they don't
want Los Angeles in the [ __ ] suit
that's more than that then the [ __ ]
crime thing in Atlanta way more we've
seen rival teams play in rival city now
let me see because is it the replay
people they're just listen to audio
we're looking at the replay of this
illegal [ __ ] hands to the helmet
where they clearly Rock Tom Brady right
in the face
he got clocked right in the face j-money
I must have right oh of course
I mean he's lucky to have his head still
on because he got hit so hard in the
face and here it comes we got hit in the
head wow that drives me nuts he did
touch a little bit that's so gay to be
clear I'm not defending the Cole no I'm
not no now all I said was he barely
touched it which you would agree he
barely touched
I let me see it again I'll see it again
you don't know I don't I actually don't
I actually don't because look when is
when he slides it his pulls his head
down a little bit and then when he comes
back his form rubs against the side of
no I'm not defending it know it's coming
making me defendant no you're not
defending it I don't bad call bad call
is he defending it it's a bad call make
[ __ ] they should take cleat Blakeman out
and rape him here it is here comes [ __ ]
oh my god maybe on the bounce-back solar
pad watch this this is the angle they
see he swiped it a little bit there it's
a bad caller right watch watch watch his
face see he swiped in there the helmet
got pulled down the helmet got pulled
down a little bit
helmet got pulled down a little I'm not
defending it literally are no I'm just
saying it won't make it
you're not joining on in a bucket oh my
god [ __ ] it's bad do it because I've
already watched it it's a game-changer
and the other terrible not a call yeah
there was like oh they can't review it
now there's only me I made the call it's
so reduce the call and the guy just says
you didn't see it right that's what his
excuse me the ref says he didn't see it
yeah wha you see this one
how were they breakdown that is the
Internet is undefeated I mean that is
like passing fancy that is the best
thing I've ever seen in my life I mean
that's why I mean there's three calls
they could have made on that Saints play
helmet to helmet holding pass
interference and four calls and now two
single one wonder why say what I am
listen here's the whole thing I don't
think they go I don't think they go um
do you blame the Clintons for this yeah
one more three times a charm
um I don't blame the here's what I don't
think they going going okay we're gonna
rig it what they do is like do they have
a moment that they could like stop
momentum one way or the other I think
they did that you know and then you see
where they broke down where that ref
played for the Rams before he would used
to be a ram I didn't know that yes well
I know all three refs were from Los
Angeles people keep making the thing
about that that doesn't make a
difference and there was a guy who had a
head judge and every time the head judge
has roughed the game for the Rams
they've lost and it's the first time and
he was pulled from the game the funniest
thing was Todd Gurley changing jerseys
with the ref was that real he's very
NSYNC pants he's got Saints football
pants on yeah they'd say odd gold pants
and then that one who's the old Morgan
look at that tell me that's not
passenger France he didn't touch him
before the ball was there after what
they've called this year to do do so
much flimsy head wasn't turned on he
broke every rule he faced guarded by a
lot
yeah his head wasn't turned around he
went there at all he wasn't making a
football move towards the ball every
single thing he did was wrong there
except for a play for the Rams that's
the only thing he did right yeah I think
the official excuse was that he didn't
see it I think that's what he told he
didn't see what he didn't see to play
the ref didn't see the play that's what
he said oh there's a picture of him
staring right at ya that's what he told
Peyton I think that was like I didn't
catch it
I'd have to is it video is it a photo
I don't trust photos okay well this was
a hard one NFL head referee Bill Bennett
versed in C comfortable
I don't know [ __ ] ba horse say that
Peyton Peyton is the funnier thing in
that phone oh you know what this is
actually this is the head of referees
saying he they send him out to talk to
the press pool and he says after the
game oh I still haven't I personally
have not seen the play can you believe
that after all the [ __ ] about wait right
after like a day later let's see huh
cuz I guarantee you by the time he got
to his car look at this I'm none of us
for the head referee of that game how
many times how many how many times how
many tax or tweets did you get on that
play just being a nobody with nothing
involved hey I'm a Sam well 1012 yeah
2012 head that the head referee for that
game yeah I was like I didn't see it
right after the game look at your phone
everybody you know sent you a what the
[ __ ] wrong with you - problem yeah
yeah probably I would imagine I mean
they fired a rough this year for being
so bad well they should fire about four
of them for this weekend they're going
to do they're gonna get I'm dude I love
listening to the NFL got exactly what
they wanted Tom Brady versus Hollywood I
can't go go go of postseason no you know
why they don't cuz they got him for the
next [ __ ] 12 years you got Tom Brady
and it's like Jordan on his last two
years you don't think the NBA
one Jordan in the [ __ ] postseason and
the finals the last two years of his
career
no matter how great cook young Kobe and
young Shaq were no matter how they go
we're gonna ride them for the next
decade
we gotta milk this cow and get every
last drop see his pants and that's Brady
he's got a Saints pants somebody who's
the old guy who's the old guy mad Mike
in the mad dog Mike was named he did a
whole [ __ ] thing I was going off about
Gurley doing Knight also his hands are
black and he's got yeah he's got [ __ ]
yeah dude and he's got Saints pants I'm
like that's clearly photoshopped and
he's awesome undefeated and he's also
still wearing the ref jersey that he
gave to the guy like he's still wearing
the same shirt that's clearly fake
everything about God's sake and
everybody's gone nuts so many of you
were like tugger Lee has such a good
sense of humor for doing that like he
didn't do that yeah some dork did that
yeah man yeah so the Super Bowls coming
it's Patriots versus Rams and you gotta
get it on that action getting that
action a bat DSi bet the acai for all
your bat needs go to my favorite time to
go to bed DSi which is prop bets for the
Super Bowl yeah you can bet on the coin
toss you can bet on every single prop
bet and they are great at having prop
bets a bet DSi next week we'll talk
about some more than ones they have as
they come up
yeah but they are great at prop bets you
literally could take the free $25 that
we give you if you use a code punch 25
you get 25 free bucks throw all of it on
the Super Bowl to five prop bets at
parlay them go a heads and tails go
who's gonna [ __ ] score first how many
[ __ ] touchdowns will it be how long
will the national anthem be I always
Scout that out videos singing let's look
that up because Aretha Franklin for 2012
I guarantee you that's gonna be sure
I'll take the under with her dead
[ __ ] ass
hey [ __ ] her and again [ __ ] you Jesus
Gladys Knight Gladys Knight Gladys
Knight oh that could be long
Gladys and I could do a nine-minute
national anthem before it even starts
it's just her farting in a diaper old
[ __ ] Gladys Knight with you everything
what is wrong with you what are you
looking up I'm trying Mattie what the
Reid is right now he's writing down what
you're saying if I printed these out
what because usually when you're looking
you're like oh I'm looking at the end so
if I print these out ahead of time can
you not have a laptop and a phone no si
for all your Bettany's go there use the
promo code punch 25 get that 25 but in
cash is that the code that's what you
read no that's what I had to because the
offers changed but uh oh is that right
yeah interesting thank you sounds got B
business some would think you might have
done that before we were alive yeah
everybody else on the show I was so yeah
man go make bets on that we've decided
not to do a Super Bowl show sorry guys
no but I'm not gonna be here Tibo nobody
there nobody will be here so that's Ben
where are you guys going where are you
going I'm not going anywhere so I want
to know where you're going to be I will
be at my good friends here Tiana's
what's your one five five six gumption
boulevard in El Segundo California one
five five six gumption Boulevard that's
Sarah Tiana's home address stalk her
somebody saw her [ __ ] head off what's
it give out her address you that gave me
an idea how about we you have like a
certain quota you have to hit like how
many people can I find I have to hit all
these 15 oh wait till I get to the my
baby [ __ ] take later wait seriously
guys the week of the podcast Super Bowl
there's no spod cast no we're doing a
podcast no just a party you summon a
party oh you mean no one's coming to
your house to watch no no okay sits
absentee mom coming back in our lawyer
going to do a show yeah Sycamore tavern
but nobody would be there but me but
everybody was gonna make money on it
I'm like why does everybody gets paid
but I'm just be the guy that has to sit
there from 3 to 10 o'clock at night
twisting your arm twisting your arm no
literally touching my arm yeah like goat
instead of do what you want to do go to
Sycamore tavern from 3 o'clock till
10:00 p.m.
none of your I'm sorry I you want to be
that you're late for do you would like
to make money you wouldn't be there yeah
I've been working I've been there and no
but but you're not yeah everybody else
but so no one's gonna be there right by
me so like why would why would we do
that because it's money yeah but it's
like it's money you're in your late 40s
200 bucks yeah no and you know it would
have been 200 bucks it would have been
sponsorship cash which would be more
money Sam I'll go just me by myself
unbelievable grown-ups not unbelievable
yeah no no do that and make more money
doing something that people would be at
yeah that was my argument go that was my
argument that was my argument you guys
would do a show if some goes hey here's
a couple grand you're gonna do a show
for two people I would go do the show oh
I'm getting 2 grand for 2 people
I'll do it it's done Oh God I didn't
know it's too late your chip $4 and
Noah's two grandmas your hamburgers
brought to you by Bette DSi Jason go eat
it while you sleep on your leaves are
you [ __ ] serious dude I didn't know
it was 2 grand for two people I didn't
know that yeah it could have been that
for sure dude oh I didn't know I I take
it back yeah - I was gonna make two
grand you didn't tell me unbelievable
times making two grand tell me that we
are what I made two grand each yeah
they're selling out baby Wow anyways so
go to bed DSi use the promo code punch
25 and guys they'll also up to $500
double whatever you put in and I'm
telling you I'm not [ __ ] around now
is the time to get in action on that I
made for my sweet manny pacquiao baby
did you
Adrien Broner hey did you see he's got a
detached retina possibly Manny Pacquiao
in his career might be over Oh
his career is kind of already over he
looked pretty good that dude he dead he
did look good but he's long in the tooth
as they say yeah like what is yeah 44
Marty yeah four or five more fights max
forty years old money makes he's making
more than $2,000 to people hey yeah yeah
hey Pacquiao I would go to [ __ ]
Sycamore tavern and watch the Superbowl
with no one you know for nine hours
we're not here friends there no Sam no
nanny no nobody child come to this I
didn't I was dying last week and you
don't demonstrate it I love doing comedy
chaos and I was like this is the one day
oh my god you guys did you guys hear how
much money
[ __ ] your mom's house got for their
studio from McDonald's no what what
McDonald wait what does McDonald's doing
there they sponsored the studio Oh
what number do you think McDonald grand
okay that's the most amount of money
I've ever heard what do you think dude I
couldn't there's no way there's more
money than 300 million dollars 1 million
2.5 million [ __ ] your life what yeah tom
was talking about it
on the podcast about the negotiation no
he's no this is like the rental car
remember he rented that Ferrari or
whatever and made everybody think he
just bought it for are you sure this is
not like a I think it's real can they
buy a house no cuz they already know
they rent because Tom wants a huge flash
treehouse and Christina thinks it's done
why would McDonald they don't own the
house
dude they make so much money that's why
own a house inside a house it's really
dumb I know it's dumb
Tom's like that he likes like run things
I don't get it yeah that's weird because
housing is like the one thing you do
want buy because it increases in value
right yeah you'd live I don't know one
bike a car yeah but like yeah not to buy
I'd be only not just blocks
that's insane they just get like money
after money well dude it's such a great
show and they're so smart the way they
work I can't McDonald's really they
don't like a risk or here's the story
okay so thank you Donald's tell me the
story it's like what an [ __ ] you're a
hundred listen listen listen listen
listen
like a hundred grand maybe a hundred
grand for the show - ah to build your
studio I wouldn't take it they're like
yeah Tom's like nah he's like okay we'll
give you 250 thousand just one of your
permanent now we don't want to do it
McDonald's goes okay [ __ ] this 2.5
million dollars and he's like okay so
now only God do is have McDonald's
product and they can [ __ ] on them making
[ __ ] is why I don't this is it this
doesn't seem I don't think it's you know
what they're you know what they do on
their show right yeah talk about
[ __ ] yeah and yeah I know a thousand
one thing isn't it smart not smart to
talk about how much money you're getting
I liked a vision board our show and go
like Mike thank you our new sponsor
let's take our new sponsor Burger King
which is way better than that [ __ ] house
McDonald's Burger King a new sponsor of
punch-drunk in 2019 Burger King for all
your burger needs and we can we hang a
really depressing vision board in here
it's a bag of leaves it's a Super Bowl
party with nobody at it and like picture
me - two thousand dollars which is the
most I ever would have made on this show
in my life your balls with the Taser
just Sam's yeah yeah yeah we gotta get
back to that dude let's taste me I swear
to God I am willing to kill myself on
this show live if it will make money for
Sam and fight nany not Johnny you don't
get a dollar no dollars no dollars can
you write that in your will well it's
bad Will Hunting and I called into the
Showtime about Chad's Ewok stole credit
cards what's the matter
what's the number dude we can also talk
about how Chad sumac
he hates black babies have you heard him
talk about that [ __ ] live he will bye
Chad
it's called bye Chad I mean I guess you
have 30 basically what happens is I
listen Chad calls in calls me and I
really does he know though you're
recording I've told him I am recording
every call you just release them and he
doesn't even know I really leaves
whichever one I want to I recorded every
call and I decide whether I want to put
it out or not yes 3 2 3 2 A 2 7 4 2 full
literally on the screen in front of you
it's on the screen calling which our
story about Chad sumac okay also on a
call we should also call up where it is
McDonald's plate can you play that she's
drinking a shake I mean you can't really
play it oh why that's good I like that
idea for a podcast we just play other
people's podcast that's we're live
archives yeah if we just play your mom's
house and we show up go hi guys and
here's a new episode of your mom's house
and then we just bounce so while we do
our Super Bowl pics no the spread is
like three yeah I think right now it's
but right around three four kids oh no I
oh I thought it was favoring the Rams
perhaps are barely favored and I think
that's like you know they say home-field
advantage is automatic three points yeah
like if it's an even game they make the
spread two and a half just cuz of the
home team yeah I think the Patriots are
getting that because they've been in the
Superbowl so much they've been there so
much it's kind of a home game for them
no matter what the stadium one and a
half point favorites yeah okay and it's
also bad that it's strictly because
they've been there like outside of
Kareem
Kate Quigley who are the rant of diehard
brand fans we know this is I mean people
becoming Rams fans but like how many
people are going to try for our crisis a
big Rams okay so it's three first
Eleanor Eleanor is Darren Carter
Darren Carter is I mean like I'll know
man okay hello you're on this can't go
bad oh that coffee is that coffee does
somebody have coffee doing it come do
what we are doing a show and we have a
call yes give it up for my keeping
promised coffee in the studio and and I
just won't [ __ ] it wish list a [ __ ]
camper I go I put camper I was like dude
let's see if we're in Bush spitballing
write anything you want coffee camp our
vision board will work you don't have to
do it yeah yeah hey can we start Klan
meetings here that's my [ __ ]
vision board let's get some Klan
meetings the Ku Klux Klan is supported
by punch-drunk
and all things coming to point five
million dollars hey by the way if the
clan wants sponsor this podcast for 2.5
million dollars we're listening will
even take one listen well it was $20
magic the Klan caters don't listen
we are $20 and free McDonald's we decide
not spend money I'm math this week and
we're gonna take all that money and
sponsor your podcast
how much does meth by the way that's a
cheap drug right yeah yeah it's like the
white version let's get meth let's get
meth as a sponsor I will give us $20 a
year I will promote meth I will take
dude seriously I will let that's $3 a
sponsor I mean like dude oh my god who
care I don't think they're allowed to
advertise so you're a [ __ ] you see my
magazines like oh Willy Johnny then
watch this I promote our new sponsor
marlboro lights
marlboro lights for the smooth tasty
cancer all children should smoke
cigarettes photo a baby max
honey that's literally tens of dollars a
decade for you hi we have somebody
calling in again but let me tell you if
anybody walks you with coffee or talking
about sponsorship from the Klan we're
gonna talk about that hello hi you're on
with punch-drunk how can I help you
hello can you hear us and is this the
guy with the chanting maybe there a guy
hello hello hi hi you're live can you
hear us okay
thank you Sam you told this person I
said dad it's Sam seems like what's a
woman's name
what Johnny Johnny Woodard Johnny Winter
Oh guys I'm three Mexicans I mean this
might be the meth guy sponsor I'd like
to give a shout-out to my shoutout just
coming out just giving up on this guy
before I quit the show
shut up for Sam's phone second of all
like shut up from the shoutout and then
like bye bye Felisha come everybody
sounds like Jason Killearn doing the
Mexican does that did that guy just
sound like Jason Gaylord dude and his
everybody ever taught in his school Oh
people and inspire a dog like you when
you tell us we got student another day
we don't get [ __ ] for that dog like we
don't get nothing for it dog
you know what [ __ ] Jose you just got
student of the day tight I'll take it
[Laughter]
have you seen promo code oh it's great
it's great it's great I look I'm the
only one I haven't listened to is the
new one Go Go learns podcast each one
told me five minutes
oh and they're all just like I need
about here whatever new dumb sponsor it
is like [ __ ] I can't even I want to
but listen to the promo code podcast
Jason learned there's only five or six
episodes but they're all short of [ __ ] I
hope it makes it to 10 yeah well he
doesn't new one every week it's very
funny the problem is you can never have
a real sponsor because people just
assume it's fake it's literally like my
dates out the gates was a podcast yeah
looks like every one of them is fake and
every one of them is so [ __ ] stupid
did this episode is brought to you by
Shazam's calzones dude I met this
[ __ ] guys Shazam Shazam is coming out
as a real movie it looks horrible
of course it's horrible it's a remake
right yeah by the way the old Shazam
with the show was great
this was poor I saw Kazaam Shack movie
yeah but Shazam is a so it's not a
remake Aaron oh I saw the TV show about
it he always cartoon he's like she
thinks it's the show because he hated
why do you think it beats his wife was
horrible really did it get like 0.0 like
on Rotten Tomatoes I didn't see that but
I would give it that it's really bad
it's impossible for him to [ __ ] that up
wait what unbreakable and [ __ ] and my
channel on made a bad movie no thank you
no really bad what happened to that guy
hold on that one movie split was good
that was a good movie
so was unbreakable yeah unbreakable
Super Bowl was like two years ago they'd
have a nice baby because it's the sequel
to both of those yeah so these two or
two of his decent movies equals a
[ __ ] complete [ __ ] show yeah but if
we know anything about babies
oh you weren't here last week we got a
new bag of bats oh no yep one of us has
to knock up a girl to different girls in
one week and not tell him about it not
tell the woman just be like sorry
there's rape in the bag about I was
gonna say but you would know you know
when you come and this is let me know
how bad it is that's exactly what that's
why I'm doing this like bad Bruce Willis
is that bad a ham comes out in the
picture worse than that and Bruce Willis
is great in it all the actors are good
in it but you know the guy that does
like all the characters and like because
he plays like nineteen different people
and split yeah
so it's hi James McAvoy yeah they find
out that like look good yeah it was good
really good he's like 19 split person
now is he has like 19 different
personalities and one of them's a serial
killer and once I mrs. Doubtfire oh yeah
in this movies like a tiger they realize
in this movie that like if you flash a
light at them like it changes its
personality so it's just the whole movie
is like I do declare the baby yeah wait
so what happened to ours that makes for
like a lame superhero though right
because when he's in his beast mode all
you guys do is well take his picture and
that's it yeah that's right that your
kryptonite is just the camera Wow
imagine him in a disco dancer with
everybody I've never been born
Ibrahim Lincoln oh no it's [ __ ] weird
becoming so now I'm dancing with [ __ ]
Helen Keller who knows she could hear me
I would love to see Abraham Lincoln
Whitley Cummings and Helen Keller
everyone better than this it's sucked
brow I went by myself what made you want
to go see that well because I saw like
the first two yeah I like the first two
and I was having lunch with a friend and
she left
Jackie old and I had lunch and I was at
that literally that theater right on
Sunset and Crescent Heights where the
gym is called gym or whatever that gay
gym and gay goes to five yeah so she
and it was like 1 o'clock and I'm like
I'm gonna head home and then I looked
you know I'm like oh let me see what
movies are playing and that started in
like 15 minutes
I love that's here and I'm like oh I can
just go one theater it's a nice theater
it's a nice theater and I'm like that
movie starts in 15 minutes I can just go
by myself and just watch this movie
which I want him to see it's like 1:30
starting it's like 1 tan I'm like [ __ ]
it I wanna go see this by myself big
mistake big mistake I'd rather be in a
Ku Klux Klan meeting our new sponsor by
the way Burger King marble lights the Ku
Klux Klan thank you for being a
participant in the punch-drunk world I
got contacted by producers of snuff porn
oh I bet doubt I bet that happens all
the time do we wanna do have snuff porn
I'll sponsor this big absolutely yes
yeah no it's not porn yes I don't hear
what is stuff porn I don't care where
they die I hope so they don't always die
so they didn't really write you're
making a joke because I was like what
took so long for you to get that off all
the stuff you've done come buddy show it
makes a couple child rapist hit me up
and they wanted to sponsor our show and
I go yes yes yes what advertise they
want to reach out to more children call
back and say you're a daycare and that's
how you do that you don't say we're
child rapist up front that's your
parents aren't taking their frivolous
with their cash I don't agree with all
this I don't even I like this car I
never like you're the one that said
snuff form literally literally I go see
bad cold smell you won't let her know
there's gotta be a band I thought you
have movie called snuff porn I wouldn't
see a band called snow porn but I would
see a movie called snow there's a band
called snuff porn oh my god
mr. snuffleupagus snuff at huh snuff bad
guys they started in 86 has a little
work and they stopped in 86 oh look
who's in the band Fat Mike now they're
active again 94 to present it says Wow
Mike they got back together that wreck
is their label um fat rack that's
probably Fat Mike and somebody else
coming together I obviously I would
assume you're rooting for the Rams oh my
god I forgot we're talking about
football
big-time no we're talking about snuff
and our new sponsors but yeah big-time
dude your football take sir and now you
are we gonna picked it in them we got
another week we got to talk about this
all right it could change you can easily
change
yeah it could easily change I mean we're
not
I guess we're technically making our
predictions but we're more so talking
about the result let's talk about the
game a little bit more what what's going
on with Todd Gurley guy didn't play 11
carries and a touchdown or no yeah 11
touches me you know dude he was hurt a
lot in college I think you know I think
he's banged up and I think they went
then CJ Anderson was freshly yeah and I
go let's save him and it work
yeah say what you want to say there in
the Super Bowl and now he has two weeks
to rest yeah the heal for sure whatever
is ailing him I mean like he was a
college and then um fournette was hurt a
lot in college and that's been his two
years in the league game ever long yeah
but you don't sign them Ronettes Marine
is a bear oh yeah for sure dude I would
I would I would pony up cash to girly
yeah I don't know if I would do that
with Finn it well I mean what do you do
fake an injury so he didn't have to run
the last game which I mean I get that
you're like we're not playing for
everything I'm taking hits but I want a
leader I want a leader right I don't
want a locker room cancer I don't want
to I don't want to give my franchise I
don't want my highest paid person to be
a locker room cancer is that somebody
locker room cancer but that is that the
rumor that locker room can the entire he
was at least that game for Carrodus
colors at 10 yards for four carries 10
yards for the touchdown
CJ Anderson and a touch on yeah an touch
now 16 carries 44 yards for two we can
we talk about CJ
adds to my theory that so they don grant
was thrown the season
well they had 26 Russians oh I mean or
you could argue that for all five teams
well do what I play for the Panthers if
we had him have to see so he played and
he didn't get on the field at all this
is his fourth team this year yeah but we
didn't really have a righty running back
at all well yeah I'd Lynch Lee got hurt
yeah so it's just like it did it's my
theory dude many times a day do you say
my theory my every day I bet no all the
time every sentence ends with Mike but
that's my theory that's my theory he
played for Carolina Oakland in LA
Carolina but Carolina twice or well we
got in white there he was he was cut
last offseason from Denver there's one
or twice he like got signed by somebody
went somewhere else and went to somebody
else again like this was his 14 daddy
was live he was basically a road comic
like he lived out of a suitcase all
season yeah yeah yeah all season he
lived out of a [ __ ] hotel and it's
funny it's like that just lets you know
look at that running back group Monta
ball didn't let I mean so weird you just
can if you just go to the wrong system
and your skill set doesn't just fit with
that system oh yeah you're [ __ ] a same
NBA yeah well especially well baseball
may be the only one that that doesn't
really apply to I I think there can be
imbalance you get to that age though as
a running back you can still be pretty
good and they don't want anything do
they want the wrong guys I got the young
guys yep yep yep yep yeah you're
starting to see that with with coaches
who's the guy behind camera oh great
yeah like Ingram use trying to see that
with him you see that with all those
guys that are like basically your whole
backfield other than white whitey
Johnson yeah I love yd Johnson well you
tell McCaffrey McCaffrey yeah well CJ
and the camera he's the white camera
yeah and they should use it more like
that like put him in the slot put him in
receiver they don't do that enough with
him I don't think Carolina well because
they were too busy running him yeah
right up the middle and if they
I'm still pissed about the Panther
season day we were six and two when I
left town yeah well they lost seven
games
but you had Klan meetings to attend hey
we're not throw it up you got us a
sponsor
oh if anyone got it that's what I was
doing I was in heavy negotiations for I
love all minorities and I love women it
was me and Artie's culture this guy
talked about Chad sumac and Noah is it a
text you got sexting fabulet car no it's
a Twitter Oh Craig cards look you might
not be listening so so you go Rams I go
Rams what's your take cuz I know that's
I think the pads gonna win what we're
talking about this what's more important
to the NFL Tom Brady's back crime great
name is 606 ring which puts them in
Jordan level neither there these are
there no but six is a number that's a
magical number no one nobody will ever
touch his numbers ever never say never
ever never say never I miss you well you
slap him don't say how about our new
sponsor
never our new sponsor is never thanked
you never go to use the code never
hashtag punch huh
hey Sam honestly I think I'll tell you
why I'll tell you it's a no-lose for the
NF oh listen I think they're delighted
what if Ellie wins if they're handing
the baton but when the Lakers took on
the Celtics I'm Kobe Bryant's last ring
okay and it's Game seven and it's in LA
and in the second half the Lakers are
getting [ __ ] lit up Kobe can't hit
anything
the Lakers go to the go to the lead go
to the line 25 times the the the the
Boston Celtics go five times okay are
they big o of a shoot foul shots okay
that is to me saying the NBA wanted kobe
bryant going for a six ring you're
saying what would the NFL water in the
NFL prefer I know I agree with you'd
like it's literally this it already
happened yeah we watched them officiate
both road
that they wanted they wanted both road
teams to win we watch them officiate
both of them to overtime both games went
to overtime and they got the Super Bowl
they want whatever happens in the Super
Bowl they're fine with cuz if they lay
wins it's handing a baton to the big
market hey Rams and now we'll finally
hopefully get a fan base here which they
desperately want that they don't want
half of this remember one knows Cowboys
Rams two games ago yeah you're my
opposite Cowboys laughs yeah and the
Cowboys scored that first touchdown and
they showed the audience it's a home you
if I literally if you look at that
audience and you just turn your TV on
you're like wow Cowboys have a home game
right now and then they paying back you
know wait a minute they're outside you
know II mean right they don't want that
so or like you're saying they get to
LeBron [ __ ] Jordan go thing and he
got another [ __ ] Super Bowl and like
but no one will ever touch it you know
see how big that Patriots versus Kansas
City Chiefs numbers were on TV the
numbers came out you had a huge had to
be used the last time the last time they
played the last time they played it was
one of the best times of the year what
am i guessing number oh you know I mean
people do you think watch that game they
said number give me a number we'll go
fight now I'm trying to reach that guy
of about the Chad thing he's looking at
marceca Creed okay you telling someone
to get off their phone on a podcast is
redonkulous yeah okay ah so there's 300
million people in America it's the
biggest second biggest football game 37
million
okay that's your thoughts Johnny ten
percent of the country forty five
million
okay you heard their numbers you just
yell out of number just say anything you
know I was closer forgetty
she got spaghetti fifty all right she
won it same two million to two million
fifty two million people
what watts
that game that sounds about right that's
huge number that is the NFL just toy
tits dicks top 12% of America watch that
game right unbelievable dude
factoring in homeless people people that
are at work everything 12% oh the people
outside of Sycamore tavern just weekend
I would have made two grand had I just
sat in Sycamore taverns roof top yeah I
believe that I'll give you what about
the Rams game if I could just get dollar
for every person watch that game yeah
that's what boom Shakalaka sounds like
there's like a big sporting event he'd
be like how many people are there and I
go 78,000 if I could just get one dollar
from everybody when they leave how much
would I have I go I just [ __ ] told
your dumb ass yeah $78,000 oh okay yeah
you know what a producer hit me up from
America's Got Talent
oh and they want me to get him on you
know in the first week when it's like a
crazy persons on there and they have
that like human interest story so I'm
working on getting boom Shakalaka onto
next season of America's Got to em
what's his talent who sell you t-shirts
for a dollar he would do stand-up he'll
do it three minutes that oh what's he
gonna beat the Jews he would kill Jews
have you ever seen him actually do
stand-up well he actually does well he
couldn't do two sets like if you wonder
when he's not dressed and drugged
exactly when he's dressed in drag it's
like why are you much competition no he
just he just hams it up too much
yeah but what he's just like crazy and
his natural self it's when he's just
what's 12 inches long and white not a
goddamn thing you know he's got all
those jokes that actually do well he
would do a three-minute set and do okay
yeah and then America's Got Talent I
would go and I get my tickets from see
cake everybody I go on seek you probably
could I would I buy my takes ago see my
good friend rocket on America's Got
Talent guys go to see key calm use the
promo code punch drunk and get $10 off
your first purchase 10 bucks dawg
and I've been going again Super Bowl
tickets Johnny look up cheeky can see ya
all ticket
they already have them up there because
that's how good our friends
I used C key I've been going to see a
couple Clippers game I've gotten a lot
of games this year me Tommy God love
we've gone to a couple games I loved it
I've been I mean I did some DMT and I
went to a game once that was a lot of
fun and yeah dude are those holy Kyle
dude what's the lowest you can get dude
that's not that bad yeah bad 99,000
we're talking about this Super Ball yeah
okay it's a twenty nine two point nine
yeah thousand I see all of the tickets
are guaranteed you don't have to worry
about getting a swindled everything on
it is legitimate and when you go there
they will tell you by the way you are
rise up Falcons that's the stadium rise
up more like crash and burn that's a
stadium right there
I feel off set a San Diego Raiders fan I
love that they show you the picture of
where what you'll see when you're there
yeah that's great you can literally look
at your view that's another great
feature on the app actually a good point
where it's like you can not only look
see where the seat is they give you a
point of view of like this is what your
seat will look like when you're there I
love it dude it's so easy now to get
your tickets is easy go boom I've been
do it I mean I love going live events if
I was in town next week and I we going
to that Bellator fight they got a fight
the forum I love seeing fights at the
forum and we go to more boxing matches
man see any boxing man that was so fun
I'm waiting the three of us lenses I
hate and it was like we went for like
and again we went
thanks for good friends at see geek we
got $6 tickets and went to an HBO live
boxing it I love that and it was super
fun super fun all three of us had a
great time and there's a bunch of people
there were a bunch of fans that
recognized as here's one oh dude that
might not be useful y'all know this yeah
I got my yourself here was it Microsoft
theater that is across free from the
Staples Center oh that's all oh yeah
yeah right in yeah Leo Santa Cruz and
Miguel Flores that's good well that's a
good whites PBC dude some grey box he's
been going on huh that's 2 p.m. on
Saturday February box occu boxing for
the last year so bad oh can we please
get in
can we get a holiday so it's like go to
we were very thankful they're sponsoring
the show tickets 38 bucks man
I will go dude yeah dude yes yes yes yes
I want to go we should go to one event
every every month thanks to our friends
at Sikhi we should grab some even if
it's a concert even if it's I wish I
went to that Chris Cornell [ __ ]
tribute show I wish by the way was like
five and a half hours long and all of
its on YouTube now so I'm like oh I'm
glad I didn't go because I can just
watch it on YouTube I would like to go
watch that live those things aren't
gonna happen again yeah yeah yeah you
know Oh
forty bucks that's nice nice that's nice
see what go to the orange let the other
red dyes like hey dude this is a bad
deal that's that's not the knot and by
the way how great is SeatGeek for doing
that of like hey this ticket is for sale
but it's not a good deal you don't want
it you want these other ones you should
punch wrong and that gets you 10 bucks
off your first purchase hey you find a
ticket like we went we went and saw
boxing for 6 bucks
yeah that's free yeah they actually owe
you four dollars if you that's not only
is it free you get you paid four dollars
we have a call if this reading hey guys
we hey so thank you see oh let's bring
the call on we have a call who's this
caller you're on the air caller
Oh caller all right ma'am is my stomach
hurts I get so many how the calls never
work
hello well the funny thing is people
like what like sorry anxiety your calls
no no just like when you listen to the
show it's so annoying and it could be
such a smooth I don't know your calls
never work I'm like no we take your call
you just are a bunch of dumb box yeah
that call was brought to you by doc
Ock's clan let's talk about ESPN Plus
and how about it okay did any of you
know that we are gonna get to watch
fights for our game cuz I did it I
didn't know I don't know where I are I
am not dead I mean I knew the GS pm+
thrid percent do you have seen UN make
so much money ESPN you don't need to
jack me for 10 bucks I've been paying
for the magazine for so long and they
just gave it to you for free if you
subscribe to the magazine so I draw oh
are you on brow I love this punch up
this is punch-drunk thank you welcome to
fighter in the cage ground control to
mouth you peep your phone suck it's not
the cusps callers oh it's not in studies
oh are you they where are you when you
answer it 54 like 30 seconds in it
doesn't make any noise and then you guys
start talking are you the guy with the
Chad zoom I can tell yes welcome to
let's hear a party here stories brought
to you by the new podcast by Chad listen
to Sam's calls with Chad and see how
long he can go before it hangs up on
Chad alright so what's his story about
Chad zoom and zoom on we should talk
about it again later to what New Year's
party with these old people and they're
just sitting around watching Jim
Gaffigan and [ __ ] listening the old
shitty white people pounds well hold on
when did this happen
New Year's when when was a New Year's
party nobody last news years two new
years ago no Chad stole the card a few
years ago okay story from the dotter
okay watches older installs um we just
started talking about comedy and she was
like oh yeah we saw this comedy show in
hilarities like a few months ago or
whatever it was and this horrible open
mike are open for the common with the
thaw and I was like well that's weird
open mike rizzo
open for people at hilarities who was
the comic and she goes oh it's [ __ ]
terrible local comic new mom this is a
real story this is finished okay god
disclaimer this is not real strip III
buying it okay no it's not it checks out
okay go on
so so she so she said it was this kind
Jumma cannot look well he's on an open
mic he's like a semi almost real comic
who I've seen before I actually saw you
fam I'm sorry that was a weird sound so
yeah you talked to my girlfriend I the
whole time we were actually a focus that
sounds about right if you talk about it
he was being Harry Potter
[ __ ] because that we talk like
Hermione so I gosh that was so I'm like
oh no Chad he's like a kind of a real
comment she's not a real comic stole my
mom's credit card I go what do you mean
she thought he's learning about credit
cards and I guess her mom was at a party
with Chad in her purse went missing and
like eventually her purse turned back up
was a credit card wasn't in it and Chad
Zuma was nowhere to be found
and he is eventually through like
Friends of people at the party they
cleared out the Chad had stolen her car
and so like they gave her they gave her
two tabs phone number and dad was like
oh no I didn't steal the card I borrowed
it I need to get home on the bus and
like had all these like millions of
excuses of why you stole his credit card
and it allegedly was to get home on the
bus and so after like months was trying
to get her car back and Chad making up
excuses like oh I'm not in town or I
have this big show to go do and then
I'll mail it to you and this and that
sort of cars so Chad do mock is not only
a [ __ ] horrible comments apparently
he's hey I want a white oak it to be
clear he did charge something to the
card you said right yeah okay what did
he charge again transportation yeah why
even admit it I'd be like no I didn't
take her what is wrong with him okay
okay everybody supporting new like so
embarrassing to admit that yeah let let
Chad know what you think about fun fact
Chad will be joining the show next week
I believe I think check we can have him
yeah yeah and by the way everybody leave
your wallets in your car and lock it up
your purse every yeah yeah don't bring
parties that has that that's not yeah
okay I wanna know where did Chad touch
you where did he touch you show us on
the doll where he probably sounds like
his wallet alright thank you for calling
in I'm sure this isn't gonna blow up in
our face at any point okay so I want the
thing I want to ask you about this
podcast you're so you just record
anytime you're on the phone with Chad
you're recording the clock okay and then
do you edit it just know whatever and he
knows you recording it yeah he knows the
deal
okay I go I'm going to record every
conversation we do yes okay and I just
record it so we so he doesn't get ready
and amp it up I make it natural okay
good thank you wow he really that was
hard from the stage you see thanks I
know I mean I good idea it's just funny
that he'd let you do that
I don't know like what's he getting out
of it a podcast yeah attention yeah like
how about we have a conversation and but
it's like no no how about we have a
conversation and we both get attention
from our conversation now that guy
wasn't lying now the person who told him
that could have been lying but that guy
for sure well he was he didn't make that
up Chad just calmly defends himself next
week yeah have you ever seen him calmly
doing is pretty common just like in a
funny mood yeah I mean he's really good
at at this I'm happy he's gonna be
coming on the show for as long as
whenever rre if ever are he comes back
so it should be fun should be fun
should be fun ah let's get in because I
[ __ ] write when I thought I couldn't
hate ESPN more yeah then it turns out I
can't even watch now every free fight is
a pay-per-view it's it's a monthly
pay-per-view yeah I got a pay money to
watch the prelims yeah and then some of
them will be free but then you got to go
back to the the main part isn't this is
gonna hurt the UFC so much so does the
foxy dumb the Fox thing was fine they're
so greedy dude prelims on Fox Sports 1
Dana
is playing this all [ __ ] wrong he's
blowing the biggest lead in sports yeah
yeah yeah hundred percent he is just
like the Falcons in the Superbowl
against the Patriots a fortiori I mean
you are the you are the brand of
excellence and you're [ __ ] all over
it from [ __ ] movie with John Jones
fight to LA okay
Reebok I mean yeah I mean dude colossal
fuck-ups you are just testing the breath
testing people's loyalty everything now
is people are gonna be like you know
what I don't miss the UFC but then it
gets better wait it gets better
remember last week on the show you
weren't here cuz you were dead and you
were [ __ ] Fagin off in New York or
wherever the [ __ ] you were but we were
talking you and I who's gonna be there
guy and it's Stephen a Smith you know
that's the guy the guy that's been
[ __ ] on the UFC literally there's
footage of him in the last decade saying
this ain't a real sport
you can't be putting two live people in
there striking in an elbow with the need
of the neck in it you can't this ain't
boxing now he's their expert he's their
resident experts so da my god dude when
I saw him I was bellied over laughing
down in the pockets to you the story of
a bunch of us were watching it down
there because they had somebody had a
password to use because no Josh now a
pay-per-view cuz it's now a pay-per-view
now this shitty card with a wife beater
so bad with a wife beater as your
co-main event is now if you've got to
pay $10 to watch this great horse just
kurzon saying he's just curse too easy
he is currently he's cursed man he's not
smart enough to handle his physical
gifts and he's just curse and the fact
that dude he just landed that knee I
mean like what he did to that woman is
completely wrong you know I just like I
you know I just like
first dude I mean he is but again like
there's two sides to every story what
did she do she had to do something to
get her Cummins to know she's cursed
he's cursed like a new sponsor domestic
violence
hey for all your domestic violence needs
use the code punch drunk so hand punch
your wife I mean just like did that
happen like could not I mean like he
gets this moment where maybe he could be
like I've changed my ways even though
I'm beating the [ __ ] out I thought it
doesn't novice mistake
I feel like hadn't been in the Octagon
more he might have known not to do that
sure I mean it just like another dumb
yes right [ __ ] Dana why that's his
fourth bike why would you put that guy
as the second fight so we is fine it's a
choice not smart not to mention there's
a woman on the card that just got in a
domestic violence thing she just got
literally went to the hospital because
she got beat up by her boyfriend or
husband or whatever it was yeah that guy
would kill her so it's also like double
whammy to throw him on there you need to
mean it's so dumb by the way I'm excited
about the new John wick not there oh me
too
yeah height that movie just like I don't
not a great French I don't like it so
much [ __ ] and I don't know why because
he's all he does is kill he does so many
great movies and you're like what our
good friend friend the show Tate
Fletcher was in me and Jake one yeah it
definitely dies
John for his ghost back John Mayer holds
his head down and shoots him right in
the [ __ ] head so funny oh he dies on
everything yeah but he dies in like
awesome ways but Tate told me like how
could a nice guy is and it was like
during that Christmas time I believe and
they were shooting that and so he flew
everybody that worked on the movie to
Hawaii and paid for everybody and their
family to go so like a hundred and fifty
people he paid for all of them to go to
Hawaii for the weekend and everything
was covered and he didn't even show up
to the party he just stayed in his hotel
room and watched it all on camera
because he didn't want to be jerked off
i watch i think he pulled like real
really ck
why yeah why did he watch on camera no
because he just wanted to see everybody
having fun but he didn't want to be at
the party because he would have taken
away the focus from everybody having fun
with their family like Batman so you
just watched every yeah like Bruce Wayne
more than Batman yeah
so here yeah did and that's how nice of
a guy that he is and everyone's just
like [ __ ] him man he's a [ __ ] frat
boy yeah during you can't like dude the
guy's rich and nice dude how much money
do you think he made off the matrix Oh a
gazillion I mean dude he's had to make
hundreds of millions right probably what
okay I guess eighty ones my guess you 81
million I'm gonna go net worth 200
million dollars it's that big but that
number so I have to say 200 and 100
crisis rated me yeah I got I got 150 I'm
gonna Louis guess Aron 360 more than
Sandra Bullock the puss is right he's
worth more than Johnny Depp really
that's gotta be Pirates of the Caribbean
mines oh [ __ ] that Johnny Depp spongebob
is he not the new [ __ ] he's the white
Mike Tyson your net worth that one dude
that was doing all the math and going
crazy uh who was your tire it was like
tiger blood Oh Charlie Sheen he's a
Johnny Depp is the new Charlie Sheen
Johnny Depp is pissing through money
like he looks so weird to Dana White
running this in the row has he just gone
just oh yeah please we haven't really
talked about the card because there were
some good fights on the card actually
and by the way how adorably cute is
Paige Vanzant
she's so hot for a fighter for a fighter
yeah we're putting in that row so hot
oh yeah writer yeah I felt about Miesha
Tate cuz you always said that I'm hotter
than [ __ ] face is not good that means
hey I she's just in my wheelhouse like
she's like thick
yeah and she's like tall I'm like I like
Amazon's that is a woodchuck with a
[ __ ] vagina I do okay point Johnny
boy Jack it's on those Pete look at
those teeth dude those choppers give for
a fighter or a not fighter if you met
her at a bar if you left if you some
Johnny leaving a bar with her you'd be
like Johnny well for himself tonight
good for you Johnny that's not him
walking out with [ __ ] uh cyborg yeah
but here's the thing dude how old is she
good no don't give a [ __ ] good fighter
to what how many fighters you know in
the nose like that really I mean that
don't have just this flat plus it's just
so hot to know that you would be dating
a girl that can literally take knows how
to take a punch you know what she looks
like
Tiger Woods like his ideal that's what
I'm worried yeah let's change the
subject let's talk about black strippers
buttholes during the Superbowl that
[ __ ] beating wife's gone
I'm not who's talking about marriage
who's talking about marriage no I never
said anything about a why yes pm+ is
gonna be the death of the UFC oh god it
really is it it really really is already
paying for ESPN and our cable it should
be included in our cable just like jocks
life and are they all wait they're
always gonna be on ESPN Plus that is
it's like blows my mind
I said novel we'll be on regular ESPN
but nobody told everybody preview or
ESPN play here's the other problem we
never knew until the day of the fire
yeah that's why I was like a secret
didn't I did say that I never knew that
I saw the ads like ESP I'm like oh dude
I thought it was just like an app you
could get I thought I gotta make things
convenient I thought it was like if you
wanted to watch it on your mobile device
or the laptop I just thought it's gonna
be like Fox were you like hey this is a
free card and turn on ESPN for it I like
[ __ ] and like you said if ESPN I'm
awesome I already miss it
Fox was perfect for the UFC
by the way perfect to PBC we talk about
this all the time Johnny he's like the
premier boxing championship
guy man what a break that dude got for
the UFC going to ESPN which opened this
giant void for this guy be like I got
this boxing thing we're trying to do the
UFC and steps out Heyman is out hey man
what's that other thing that's like 9
bucks and you get every fight why why I
think it's gonna be big oh no well it's
not a bait-and-switch it's not like oh
hey we're gonna have some of the food
it's a goddamn pain switch we're dealing
with that's what it is it's a bait and
switch it's like hey we're gonna be on
ESPN instead of Fox awesome I'll [ __ ] it
I literally went to the store to be like
I can watch the fights on ESPN no I
can't no I can't nobody can unless you
pay $10 so now it is a pay-per-view it's
literally a pay-per-view yeah and it did
you see how everyone's making a big deal
has so many people downloaded it but you
can cancel it right away or it's free
for a week so it's like I'm gonna save
my free for a week for a fight I really
want to see them it was like everyone's
gonna cancel it that doesn't mean it's
like of course you got a lot of
downloads there's no way that anybody
that is a fan of this sport like all of
and we've been you and I in particular
have been fans since day one I
understand since you punch someone nuts
I've been fan since a guy was wearing
one boxing glove yeah fighting a [ __ ]
lot too bouncer yeah
always we've been there's no way any oh
gee legit fans right we're like that was
a success and I'm glad that it's gonna
be like this are now on there's no way
to ends party or cable package there's
no way Sam
it's [ __ ] the worst shitty like I'm
right when I thought I couldn't [ __ ]
hate ESPN more they now make you're free
you have sees a pay-per-view and on top
of it I gotta pay $10 to listen to the
guys has been [ __ ] on my one of my
favorite sports for 10 years now
now pontificate like he's an expert
right there claiming 568 thousand new
subs from that but that makes sense it's
like it's the first time of course what
choice do you have
and what does it say the next day after
how many [ __ ] XO after the seven day
free trial how many six
70,000 people canceled you won't hear
about that I'm glad I didn't waste my
free trial on a 32 second fight by the
way cuz we saw the whole night brother
like the throw leg kicks he's literally
yeah it's the most general like asinine
[ __ ] he's the worst that they
couldn't have picked the worst guy yeah
honestly yeah I've I've hated him and
we've talked on this show in the last
eight years several times about what an
[ __ ] he is and how much he is [ __ ] on
the UFC and MMA as a sport in itself
because ESPN wouldn't cover it dude he
doesn't really know that much about the
other city now he's either I mean
literally uncle Tommy left and right
this guy that's exactly what he's doing
because corporate [ __ ] slave owner
told him not to like the sport so he's
[ __ ] on it and now they're like now you
gotta like this board I'll do whatever
you say so that's exactly what he's
doing I talked to several African
American people this weekend and they
said that hating what they're saying
okay so and then I saw these African
America but I'm just doing an impression
of what Clinton I'm just doing an
impression of what Cory Matthews in
Quincy Weekly were telling me oh yes oh
massa
oh yeah African Americans that's what I
watched the fight with them and they
were saying that they actually said he
was Kooning I'd like to this is a good
time reminder one Sam's Armenian he's
not white yes man you're the only one I
got that but we lost the Jew yeah that's
gonna cost us
well little old like theme song the Jew
that's wat the r-mo and something
horrible
whatever is yours white trash I'm
whatever is worse you you're a [ __ ] I
think all right you'll be back by the
way he's still trying to get a sponsors
and stuff he's
he cares about us as individuals he
wants like me to feed my baby but like
he doesn't necessarily you take a break
everybody takes a [ __ ] bed always
breaks are cool he travels the world is
yeah I don't know there's nobody better
than Ari Shaffir yeah nobody maybe your
mom's house
2.5 million yeah yeah by the way we're
getting a lot of Twitter feedback saying
that they appreciate that was a bit
what's up
the McDonald's thing was a bit it's a
great bit we're talking about it hey you
know what they will let a guy calling
about a bit about you know it's not
about our new sponsor Burger King Burger
King for all your burger needs what
about you guys oh yes I'm happy that he
lost he talked a lot [ __ ] I think that
was an early stoppage oh do you know
like TJ Dillashaw he talks about it I'm
the one thing I agree with Connor is the
GJ jealous I met him he's a nice guy
make in the grass he used to be a nice
guy okay but you made it when he was on
Team Alpha mill very very a long time
when he was on Team Alpha male he was
cool and then he left he uh I don't know
Sarah Lee stop it well all I got say
especially look at how he looked at the
weigh-ins they should not have let that
I mean it's a belt for belt it's like ah
no no no no I know but I'm saying two
champs are fighting and you stop it that
I thought that was an early stoppage I
thought everybody I can see what you're
saying but there was so many not early
sausages on that card that we're like
well with early Y and stoppages I sound
like you I just said ly good Oh luckier
wha he's walkin out oh stop [ __ ] with
everything but he's just so cocky it was
great to see him like rocked so quickly
it's like really but yeah when you dig
around much wait do I think he was gonna
lose that fight yeah probably and I
think it was gonna lose that fight
anyway but I'd like to see him lose it
yes not I I thought that was like an
early actually I just wanted to see him
get beat up mark they could have let it
go to an actual knock out I would like
what do you guys think in a fight Connor
vs. Cerrone well that's not an ounce but
that he called me no I think they really
I think it's guy love it yeah I think
this is an interesting fight for that
guy talk so much [ __ ] about how old it
and as a guy that's old I'm old
here's and for him to talk shitty bike
you're too [ __ ] old you're blah blah
blah you're blah blah blah and then for
him to whoop his ass like that I'm like
that's what you get oh that's what clip
them oh man that was a combo dude that
cobble I mean I was just that straight
right connected right at the sweet spot
that belt oh by the way I don't that new
belt right aces Robots in Disguise what
the [ __ ] is it looks like a little skin
elastic ax looks like [ __ ] galactica
it looks like a fighting in a Star Trek
Enterprise it looks like a little kids
Halloween costume yes hey everybody look
my child got a fake belt looks like it's
filled with chocolate yeah it's like a
Toblerone
unbelievable unbelievable and by the way
they could they couldn't have Instagram
or tweeted more things about that new
belt riot like my whole feed was like
look at we made a stupid belt I don't
give a [ __ ] do UFC [ __ ] dumb dude oh
man I really wonder what Rogen thinks
about that yes well I wasn't in Hindman
shop do their MMA podcast and they were
talking about and shop this is the day
of the fight or the day before and shops
like yeah man you got to go to ESPN plus
with the subscription and then you go
and then sir oneís fight is gonna be on
ESPN and then you got to go back to ESPN
Plus for the two main events and Rogen
goes you got do what wait wait what yeah
you got to go to ESPN Plus and pay your
subscription and then sir oh nice fights
gonna be on regular ESPN and then you
got to go back to us p.m. plus for the
two minute Rory's fight was not regular
ESPN yeah we figured out we're like wait
where's the main card yeah
well dude there are people like my and
then they went back to Maryland state
versus Wisconsin yes yes
that was so weird who gives a but might
like really like my parents would never
figure that out like they'll never see
my dad yeah you're right my dad and my
to do anything like worldwide something
where you got to go on your Apple TV
your iPad my dad I mean he's out I think
they just cut out so many people that
were watching yours forever and that's
your first ever card for UFC you do that
and I got a I watch Cerrone and then the
Cerrone fight ends and I'm like sweet
the main events about to start nope nope
it's Maryland Tech versus [ __ ] it's
women's college basketball good though
it's women's college banner Cabaye in
the heat they got vs. foot eight
lesbians new titles by people if we've
ever said anything in the [ __ ]
scissors history ah listen dude yeah
it's and here's something you remember
when uh the UFC went to Fox remember how
colossal [ __ ] that was cuz Cain gets
clipped in two seconds and the fights
over and yeah Dana White's like [ __ ]
freaking out another class of [ __ ] up
this is way worse than that well it also
wouldn't have Hardy you guys are right
there Hardy and that that was a bad call
they should have done that what a the
fact that you have seating ESPN goes we
don't want him on this coming I mean
it's almost or throw them on the
undercard don't make them domain of it
what just as a fight it's not good
enough to be a great thing on the
undercard period to see if this guy can
bang or not
don't make him the co-main event don't
make him even the main event of an
undercard yeah but now there is no
undercard now everything on ESPN is an
unrecorded you got hey let's talk about
that fight for a second though where do
you think that was heading if he didn't
do the illegal knee do you think Hardy
was struggling a little bit he was
checking a little bit I was talking a
lot of [ __ ] he was getting in his face I
mean war like he was doing that kind of
[ __ ] I mean everybody have it up can we
watch I think he's a tomato can who all
right that guy that none of us have ever
heard of even Rogan said he's never
heard of this guy
Rogan said it on the shower podcast he
goes who's he fighting and he said his
name he goes I've never seen this guy
fight I don't know anything about him
but and then showers like well he's
fought three tomato cans so obviously
this is a fourth well and then he was
they said this guy Crowder is not arrest
at all and he was giving him a lot john
madden of UFC our good friend joe rogan
wasn't familiar with this guy's skills
or hasn't seen him fight so how would we
know him I mean why is just like he
cashed out and you're ruining exactly
right when you write when I was doing
this to you you said they catch on
exactly what he did and they I mean dude
you're ruining a sport to think you'd be
even bigger but instead you're taking
the quick buck you're jumping over
dollars to make dimes that's what you're
doing dude I like that I like that I
like that that's exactly what they're
doing see what's on HBO's can't wait
Game of Thrones so I got my dad of Smart
TV they're so [ __ ] cheap oh yeah he
took it on nothing yes 120 but I just
bought one for my house 120 bucks for a
32 inch television really are like 500
for something that small do take a leak
in the years ago they're like 2 grand
right yeah so I bought my dad it and I
got a Netflix I I'm paying for the HBO
everything now he's like where can i
watch my other movies dad how much
programming do you need I thought why am
is everyday am I getting email about new
charges he's just running up the bill
that's great free [ __ ] I'm gotcha
he's just buying new release there can i
watch other mood there's an on
programming watch Game of Thrones how
many seasons is Game of Thrones alive
yeah watch that I'm back yeah weird
chasing you know probably a [ __ ] do
cope on base season so far yes sir ninth
season coming up well okay
mama what do you up do there see that's
fun Oh Oh basketball ah
I love this season Maxie can I tell
y'all I love Joel embiid I [ __ ] love
that guy
I love they talk so much [ __ ] to
everybody I love that doesn't give up
hey dude I want to be I don't want to
get long I just want to talk mad [ __ ]
well hey what about a butler Jimmy
Butler it's not working out right it's
weird
Butler's just said he's not a guy
yelling dude
this is gonna be your third flame oh I
thought that I really thought that was
gonna work dude I was so high oh man he
has no history get along with anybody
yeah I don't know but he just seemed
like he fit that team I like it seem
like you could drop him in there and he
could make it work yes he hat dude he is
the third best guy on that team did you
see what Kyrie Irving said about about
it seems like he's kind of coming to an
understanding now of LeBron because
Kyrie Irving's having to deal with the
younger players I barely call him and
apologize for being difficult in the
past that we're the problem which
Berkeley hated already what a [ __ ] move
what a [ __ ] move we call an apology I
mean like you know like Wow dude now I
see what you're trying to do I
understand that I don't think that's a
[ __ ] move I think that's like a sign
maturity but the same time Kyrie it's
like you are what LeBron was in Iran as
crazy as I think that guy is and as I
think he's getting more more I'm what a
a do to that area that that the the type
of person you have to be to get to that
atmosphere is like super selfish and
really phony as [ __ ] I mean I'm sorry
I'm gonna say it dude there's [ __ ] ease
doing where it's like hey [ __ ]
Carter's like we'll come back when we're
ready it's like hey Dawg you're on the
Lakers as much as I hate the Lakers
LeBron James in the history of that team
is maybe the six best guy just in terms
of Lakers ladies which is a pretty big
honor yeah I mean but you do actor
incorrectly like you're like you're like
Godzilla dawg welcome to Monster Island
okay
you're not Shaq Kobe the dinosaurs are
two years old but they all
wait but not Baker not a lake as a Laker
no right but in terms of Loyola the
history okay that's not the baby Lakers
shack up his Shack over LeBron you think
young Shaq vs. young LeBron absolutely
young Shaq could stay in cover [ __ ]
litter I saw remember when he got into a
fight about a while ago I saw it with in
Orlando yeah and then you seen you go
one I forgot one Jack had hair yeah I
forgot how like skinny no I'm in bulls
fool was like svelte remember him blue
chips when he was playing yeah it was
that era dude right Jack out of college
was like not fat [ __ ] and crazy chef
Josh still was had jumping Garnett's
kill attitude and business like work
ethnic it wouldn't even be debate who
the greatest player of all time was I
mean he still you could argue if you put
keep everything about you to the traps
everybody of all time how high was Shaq
on your pick list what everybody of all
time and they're all in the High Line
for today's NBA though or oh yeah
today's NBA everybody all NBA today he
would [ __ ] they would be cut they would
be working to stop he would destroy
everybody you think they would have to
hack-a-shaq again o4 do of course he
would destroy a nimble Shaq like
everyone thinks Joel I'm beads amazing
Joel beat is nothing compared to what
young chef what about Shaq ripping every
rim down when's the last time we saw
somebody not only tear a rim down but
multiple times in his career yeah he
[ __ ] broke the rim
yeah dude he's so good dude like look at
that show I'm ripping the rim look at
that guy dude it should be in here these
are his top ten magic please okay cuz I
mean this guy where did that spin move
wow dude
I mean like that's and now it's against
one of the greatest centers of all time
oh yeah do for sure dream on
for sure dude and it's just a funny
charismatic who's like a Shaq was your
neighbor you'd be so happy yeah dude he
was huge in the 90s like my grandma's
culture he was massive my grandma's
neighbor was Macho Man
when he was so cool and rapping imagine
if it was shout oh that's it so I've
ever heard yeah my grandma's name macho
man these teams should have been better
they would invite my grandma and her
husband to parties this is all he goes
and it's what Shaq the one flaw Shaq had
was he an ego and he couldn't get along
all did uh with uh with like people like
no not the guy that created it released
his own martial arts video rap album
Shaq food man that game was he's gonna
do any commercial he's almost like he's
he's doing local shitty [ __ ] oh yeah
like that he's still doing local he's a
[ __ ] Insurance commercials and you
member dude like he hated David Robinson
cuz he wouldn't sign an autograph I've
been hanging out with the general
general is the best insurance you could
have right there right there literally
broke em up in hangs with the general he
hated the Admiral those commercials are
the worst the general yeah
dude do you remember go to when are
going Gary Coleman dunked on Shaq when
that would happen how do they finish the
game they don't know I takes them a long
time they have other ones that they can
bring out but it takes like 20 minutes
but I'm to like bring another one this
is they actually in some like remember
when he was in college he broke one of
those glass rims and then they start
phasing those out around that time
because you insurance in the general
because they used to be if you broke the
rim the glass will just pour down on you
Derrick Coleman you said they're calling
dunking on Shaq like boogie cousin's all
the skills in the world just DC boogie
cousin boom and just stares him down I
used to love that here I loved him he
can't stay in shape though that was his
problem
boogie Cousins is a home I couldn't stay
fit all the skills in the world derrick
omens a terrible actor
he could ever be in cuz I'm kind of
sounds like Josh Martin too
Oh baby basically an idiot
we're doing all of my you guys want to
be in my Super Bowl poll did you do you
were you around me squares but were you
around him for the Saints game Josh oh
no no no I would rather I'd rather
literally be at a [ __ ] dentist with
getting a [ __ ] root canal not on
[ __ ] painkillers than be around Josh
Martin during a [ __ ] Saints game you
guys are terrible people you don't even
understand football like I do I love I'm
dude anything from the 9th 80s and 90s
oh I love that [ __ ] uniforms are all
better ever be NBA fights like there
used to be like we grew up with like a
real like bench-clearing line in here
just like oh here we go again I mean you
would watch
pistons-bulls in the 80s into the early
90s just because like there's going to
be some fireworks well what's the last
good one is it the the palace of mouse
the palace it's gotta be it right
the last real good one was yeah that's
where you know what game went into the
stands and was fighting people what was
that what God does male since Ron Artest
there's almost one between Ibaka and I
think Chewbacca Jones or whatever the
guy from Miami Heat like you got this
close and then I think Ibaka realizes
dude what's a martial artist like every
oh really
you hear stories that guy from these dad
used to bring his brothers into the
Octagon and they would have to fight
what do you think we only have a few
minutes left now what does if someone
wanted to bring up to you real quick um
my special is still out there
I guess start promoting that go do aw
that's what I was just gonna bring it
what a coincidence you call about Chad
sumac
haha Aaron's on fire at the end of the
pocket
Chad sumac thief go to go tweet a chat
sumac you see up go to vimeo.com put in
centrally I got two specials zero Fox
and our mo got in there by the time the
years done you might
be able to say Vimeo without saying
venmo whatever it is van Momo what I say
hmmm oh okay
go on kisstixx everybody Oh Johnson like
it got that's it nope nope the other one
that one that got closed that got closed
and I think he goes oh [ __ ] I think your
box goes oh yeah you got you know karate
what so you know you're talking by the
90s it is weird though that every when
they've had those throwback nights and
they paint the court it always looks
better than what they have now all those
uniforms are the nice agree they created
Jason still wanted to say something I'll
bring it up next week
to be continued be continued
oh he did he did Punk out right he threw
some punches and then he's like nope
nevermind yeah yeah yeah yeah cuz he
just whispered I know yeah look at that
dude you totally read lips he goes I got
a black belt in a black or dick okay
that's let's start let's have a new
checkbox where we check off all the
things I think he does that at home he's
like domestic violence don't forget my
[ __ ] Jesus yeah do that guy go on I
think we were it's no announcement and I
just wanted your opinion on something
yeah um what do you think about what
you're reading on your phone right now
yeah Louie doing a gig in San Jose and
people protesting it and why can't this
guy work they're just stupid it makes no
sense you know I think snow mine he
apologized it's fine everything they do
can we move on why can you do an armed
robbery why can bill con me people will
protest in the street saying you should
be allowed to work and let him go back
who's you know for anybody these these
Bill Cosby did a certain kind of leader
gigs he was doing a theater gig tour
while his trial was going on no and he
can't Louie don't want to like a [ __ ]
the fact that Chris Brown is torn what
the [ __ ] do you what about the fact that
people a great ago what about our Angele
are Kelly's birthday party after that
miniseries came out
and why aren't white women who are going
[ __ ] nuts saying anything these two
because white chicks are more afraid of
being called racist than they are
[ __ ] of actually sticking to their
[ __ ] point and that's why this
happens
cuz [ __ ] the same reason judd apatow
calls out him because politically it's
okay cuz the [ __ ] Momo's he runs with
in this [ __ ] beast this [ __ ] town
will plot him but if you actually went
after anybody else that didn't fit in
his [ __ ] [ __ ] and that's why this
podcast is great because we do not fear
being called racist you know and it's
just like dude he hasn't been charged if
you think the guys lost [ __ ] lose eight
million dollars when Evan long he lost
more than that well they can't they
[ __ ] [ __ ] can too movie that was
already done his [ __ ] even release it
his great oh oh wonderful it does a loss
for everybody because that show was
great lost twenty eight million Justin
stand up Justin stand up for the last
year and not including movies all
fighting like I'm not gonna say a name
but he's on the wall over there [ __ ]
calls like Brody Stevens goat no he goes
he goes dude people [ __ ] Judy's ramp
people have time like who do you run out
of town and he's like I know she'll be
right out top who named her and it turns
out this one chick said that Louie ass
could he beat off a farmer asked and she
said I know and she told everybody that
he got her fired from there and she quit
the business you know many times I've
been fired dude you know many times I
beat off in front of people ya know I
had the best take on that one by the way
but maybe your dreams just weren't you
know that by the way maybe you weren't
good enough Chappelle did the store
Sunday night apparently I still think he
might still be on stage right now so if
you want to go see Chappelle get to the
comedy store in the next four and a half
hours and I you know there's a certain
type of person like that wants to see
convicts get back you know immediately
after they get out of jail but this guy
they're saying he hasn't served long you
know he said I apologize I'm gonna take
some time off he took a whole year off a
year how long's he spoke yeah not long
enough for Steve Rannazzisi I'll tell
you
that could have made 40 million dollars
that year how long is he supposed to lay
out I mean stupid man it's just stupid
and nos we took all these same blue
check [ __ ] heads or like don't want to
admit when they're wrong about the
Native American guy and the [ __ ] and
someone who has a blue check Cosby took
a month off of it war Kelly has not
stopped working yeah Cosby took one
month off yeah I mean granted he's in
jail right now and our Kelly probably
should be or will be oh yeah but neither
one of them stopped working it at all
please don't kdd don't turn dicks dude
don't tell her all US blue check people
yeah blue checks like the kid the kids
that's how SIOP by the way [ __ ] that
whole thing is all dumper guys thank you
for joining this Christian podcast he's
a creep he's some creepy [ __ ] yeah but
what has he done it's illegal
yeah what what what has he done
he's doing crappy [ __ ] guys I'm not
saying you haven't what people are
creepy that man yeah
whoa sexist you're talking to me in
greeting area you're talking to me
instead I guarantee you Sam and I have
done creepier [ __ ] than let me see
listen dude when he told Dana and Julia
today if you history ghost you tell
anybody you're done this time that is a
[ __ ] that's horrible and he paid the
price for that's the Badham that's the
offense to me I saw worse
what's he supposed to do what's easy at
me how long is he honest it you know
they went on to have great careers man
Dana then then they sold TV shows they
started movies they did see dude it's
not like they didn't worry if they
didn't work I would have I would
understand your argument
they worked bad and that's why this
other girl it's laziness it's easy just
to blame it on somebody these girls went
worked what did what did he do he beat
off the front check do you mean off the
Kona still creepy okay creepy is that a
grimy creepies weird weird I'm weird dog
yeah
I'm weird yeah so I murdered a child I
murdered a child and I don't want to
confess to that guys kiss fix dude we
love you guys very much is that your new
thing or was it yeah kiss Nick's
kisstixx dude
suck it